bonsoir benjamin morel merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france alors on l'a vu ces
manifestations ont été tolérées par le
gouvernement un exécutif qui reste tout
de même assez silencieux sur ces
manifestations qu'en pensez vous c'est
compliqué pour l'exécutif pour plusieurs
raisons parce que d'abord in a
évidemment un ministère de l'intérieur
qui n'est pas là comme représentant des
forces de l'ordre mais qui malgré tout
est bien se doit d'avoir de bonnes
relations avec son administration et de
bien fonctionner avec cette
administration d'un côté vous avez des
revendications qui viennent de
l'intérieur et de l'autre vous avez une
colère sociale qui tout de même où
depuis un certain temps et qui se
manifeste donc ça c'est la première
grande difficulté
ensuite il ya une difficulté électorale
si vous prenez aujourd'hui
l'enquète et lab pro confrères de bfm il
ya quelques jours
oui et que les électorats sont récriées
l'électorat de gauche soutient très
humaine très massivement ces
manifestations l'électorat de droite
et là il ya une identité de ce soutien
peu de noms soutien entre l'électorat et
rennes électorat lr condamne ces
manifestations et côté lrn c'est 50 50
donc pour un gouvernement qui se vend au
centre qui a déjà un électorat cliver et
qui doit prospérer à l'avenir aller
chercher des électeurs à elle est allée
chercher des électeurs au centre gauche
et bien c'est probablement le plus
difficile sujet à traiter parce que mon
effet ces crimes
aujourd'hui fondamentalement à la fois
le coeur électorale et les cibles
potentielles des manuels marque donc il
vaut mieux rester silencieuse c'est ce
que l'on comprend emmanuel macron doit
doit s'exprimer demain peut-être
abordera-t-il cette question néanmoins
vous parlez de la droite et de la gauche
c'est un sujet a traditionnellement
clivant politiquement on peut pas
trouver un juste milieu dans ce débat il
ya des exagérations peut-être des deux
côtés sur le principe évidemment qui est
un juste milieu en termes de tactique
unique c'est à dire que on peut penser
la question des violences policières
sans forcément envisagé ni les
statistiques ethniques qui 1 sont
inconstitutionnelles de pose de vrais
problèmes parce qu'elle implique unique
et définition des indices
qui font qu'elles ne sont en fait pas
très représentative et qu'elles
conduisent souvent à des ennemis
donc il ya un juste milieu entre ignoré
des violences policières qui peuvent
exister et de l'autre mettre en place
une catégorisation des populations qui
rompt l'universalisme après dans un
débat qui est devenu politique
passionnément politique et qui construit
toute sa logique sur un retour des
clivages politiques anciens droite
gauche mais encore une fois si on prend
les caractéristiques de l'électorat
arriver à construire une politique de
modération sans envoyer des symboles qui
crissent un côté ou qui triste l'autre
c'est évidemment extrêmement compliqué
ça l'est d'autant plus en période de
prévost manning donc pour vous c'est
bête ndiaye n'a pas raison de vouloir
rouvrir ce débat sur les statistiques
ethniques jeu elles sont autorisées dans
l'est dans les pays anglo saxons elle
pourrait au moins au moins mettre les
choses au clair c'est ce que dit si bête
ndiaye de savoir réellement d'où vient
la criminalité qui quels quelles sont
les personnes en prison au moins ça
pourrait faire taire au moins certaine
certaines affirmations de certains
partis politiques
alors encore une fois d'abord elles sont
inconstitutionnelles c'est à dire que le
conseil constitutionnel ait dit non vous
pouvez toujours essayer de modifier la
constitution de doute que vous trouviez
une majorité de pays et au parlement
pour arriver à faire cette modification
donc je vois très bien si ce n'est une
incantation quels débouchés pratiques as
ensuite qu'est ce que c'est une
statistique ethnique c'est à dire que
les statistiques ethniques
ce n'est pas rendre les gens et savoir
d'entrée dans quelle case il se situe
s'est inscrit à ce moment-là vous
construisez des constitutions ethniques
qui sont à réellement objective et qui
pose un vrai problème de catégorisation
ex t'aidera de la population donc les
statistiques ethniques telles qu'elles
sont faits dans le monde anglo saxon ce
sont des statistiques qui implique
l'autodéfinition des individus qu'est-ce
que je me sens que je me sens plutôt aux
moir plutôt blanc plutôt acceptera
acceptera et là on pouvait avoir ensuite
des catégories et bien qu'ils se
construisent qui s'auto construisent qui
signe d'abord et avant tout culturelle
et qui pose un problème ensuite de
définition et de construction bref on
n'en sort pas et ça pose également
de problème on voit que même nous états
unis est plutôt un rétropédalage une
chine et sur toutes ces questions lors
d'une discrimination positive qu'il faut
être extrêmement prudent
par ailleurs et c'est peut-être le plus
important de tous les arguments et bien
la république ne reconnaît que les
citoyens et des individus et cette
catégorisation elle est profondément
étrangères à l'esprit même qui fondent
aujourd'hui notre régime est donc en ça
c'est pas forcément un débat qui qui me
semble à même d'aboutir
alors à force c'est inconstitutionnel
certes mais à force de vouloir mettre
tout le monde sur un pied d'égalité
est-ce que l'on n'occulte pas finalement
certains problèmes réels et du coup ça
crée des tensions aussi on le voit avec
les tensions existent ça c'est évident
si vous voulez et qu'il y ait des
solutions sociales politiques à ces
tensions
c'est également évident mais ces
solutions elles sont sur le long terme
alors vous avez un politique et kim
était enclenché par des buts et qui
narre vous avez vous n'avez d'autre qui
doivent être menées en termes de
politique de la ville en terme de
reconstruction et de réaménagement de
l'ascenseur social
aujourd'hui on a un ascenseur social qui
est en panne et donc à partir de là vous
avez des populations qui signifie
l'immigration et qui sont dans la
pauvreté qui reste le vrai problème il
est là ils ne sont d'abord et avec une
sociale beaucoup plus qu'un problème qui
consisterait à compter les jeux donc le
pauvre le problème réel se situe à la
base même au niveau de l'éducation avec
ces zones de non droit en france où
évidemment il ya beaucoup de disparités
sociales
c'est plus une question de disparités
sociales d'ailleurs que de que de que de
questions raciales
il ya deux il ya deux principes si vous
voulez il ya d'un côté on est chez un
problème de disparités sociales et de
panne de l'ascenseur social et ensuite
vous avez un problème d'identification à
la nation c'est-à-dire de construction
d'un commun et là c'est pas seulement
une question 2-2 de couleurs de qu
excepté râle beaucoup de mes travaux
portent sur le régionalisme vous voyez
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez au niveau des
partis régionalistes de vraies ruptures
également
même au sein du gouvernement quand vous
avez un ministre jean yves le drian qui
si on en croit le livre d'or et lagadec
lorsqu il témoignait pour le fln le flb
il ya quelques années disait que la
république française s'apparenter au
régime franquiste parce que il brille
mais les identités acceptera et comme
universalisme ça ne marchait pas eh bien
vous voyez que ça c'est également très
ancrés bien au delà de la crise des
banlieues
donc aujourd'hui cette rupture de
l'universalisme cette rupture de la dden
républicain et de l'adhésion à une forme
universaliste et républicaine de la
nation c'est quelque chose c'est un peu
l'archipel français de dire haut et fort
qu'elle singh l'est c'est quelque chose
qui est pour son démon créé et qui
auront la possibilité à s'identifier un
corps politique
et si en plus vous y rajoutez la panne
de l'ascenseur social
à ce moment là eh bien vous avez une
situation explosive
tél mon avis la panne de l'ascenseur
social finalement est ce que ce sont pas
les policiers qui font face directement
les policiers et s'est quelque peu le
paradoxe il est vrai c'est que la police
aujourd'hui composé de femmes et
d'hommes qui font partie des catégories
populaires
prenez mouvement des gilet jaune ou bleu
demandé chez les jeunes est assez
intéressant dans la première phase du
monde et j'ai les jeunes vous aviez
grosso modo d'etion qui disait aux
policiers on est pareil venez avec nous
vous n'avez rien à faire face à nous il
y à une communauté de destin pour nous
parce qu'en fait les catégories sociales
sont les mêmes ensuite il ya eu une
forme d'une position avec la police tout
un tas de raisons
et on voit d'ailleurs dont les enquêtes
que la police reste populaire et que
vous avez une baisse du soutien par
rapport à des enquêtes après une longe
les jeunes justement parce qu'il ya une
organisation des rapports sont sur
malgré la porte
l'appartenance à une même classe sociale
donc les policiers font face mais ils
sont également les premières victimes
des mécanismes aujourd'hui qui
conduisent à ce type de situation
même si évidemment il peut y avoir des
animosités sur le terrain
fondamentalement les phénomènes qui
conduisent augmenter la précarisation de
la police
qui conduisent également aux
cocotte-minute que sont des banlieues et
liens sont des mécanismes qui sont assez
similaires
merci beaucoup benjamin morale pour
votre analyse merci